Trump says you're disloyal do you feel
that way disloyal to who I mean you know
politicians have to earn support they're
not entitled to support I did a lot for
him in 2016 and 2020 by the way was
happy to do it but at the end of the day
um you know I'm loyal to my family to
our Constitution and to the good Lord
this is politics this isn't uh you know
it's not gin rummy or whatever
um this is this is just kind of the way
it is and if you're going to be this
much of a snowflake Trump I'm talking
about it's going to be tough to have
success in other areas and Trump is of
course struggling for Success from the
point of view of DeSantis the idea of
invoking God and saying my loyalty is to
God rather than to Trump again it's I
know it's a small thing but it's another
one of these examples of how they
constantly have to drag in religion
to civil government positions he's
running for a position in civil
government should have nothing to do
whatsoever with God but he just can't
resist